hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach now we just got murdered by Billy
which is always fun I'm always looking
forward to the moments when Billy can
murder us dead but hopefully we can get
back there and we can go where we need
to go because in there is the only way I
think the only way to get to the heavy
containment breach zone or the heavy
containment area but it just seems like
Billy decides to be a giant sack of [ __ ]
all the time
so he generally is just an [ __ ] and
we got to get by him so I imagine
considering he's been there the past few
times he's gonna be there again which
just means we got to deal with him and I
think what I got to do if I'm thinking
about my math right and I don't know if
I am but if I'm thinking about my math
right then I think I think funky I think
that I need to go down deactivate the
Omega warheads because to be honest the
only thing oh no not there not there no
no no ah there you are busy where you at
Billy Billy will you add Billy poo I
know you don't want me to go down there
but I think if I remember correctly from
the previous version of this game the
only thing those that the the computer
wanted from you was to turn that off
because it knew that it cannot move
therefore it doesn't want to die when
everything blows up so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go deactivate them because
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
turn off remote door control because I
don't know where that was it may in fact
be Owen also that is the nuke right
there that's the that's the five
megatons of death staring at us in the
face so I need to do that and that's
gonna be super fun in awesome but I'm
gonna turn these off because I'm
thinking I'm just barely thinking with
my big brain that just maybe he wants me
to turn those off and he'll be willing
to let me in and talk to me after that
which means that he would disengage the
locks to the heavy containment zone and
therefore we'd be able to progress but
until that happens everything's at a
standstill and regrettably if this
doesn't work I might have to go back
into the original light
Cayman areas what the [ __ ] was that
I saw that oh I saw that
hey hi okay well that's a little more
uncomfortable than I needed it to be all
right you stay right the Frick frack
there you Billy [ __ ]
all right so behind me there should be a
containment door and if I close it now
I'm not gonna get bothered by Billy
because Billy cannot open those doors
Billy does not have a key card
man I was reading up on SCP wiki entries
the other day and there's some new ones
that are really really really cool like
legitimately cool oh come on oh hi what
the [ __ ] was that oh I thought that
opened okay you're not gonna give me a
second time no all right I get it
I get it you don't want to be bothered
oh [ __ ] he's right outside
hi oh hi oh hi there you are
all right I'll just be on my way don't
mind me I oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god [ __ ] hell okay so I gotta find
remote door control access which means I
got to go back I don't know how far I
got to go back all I know is that I
gotta go back alrighty then should be
good after this it should be okay but
then again I've said that before and
they didn't work out so well for me so
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna look at my
map I think I need to go back to the
light containment areas because what I
remember and if you guys don't remember
this - oh [ __ ] huh you feel something
near you oh hey hey where the [ __ ] did
you come from why didn't you get Vivi's
zapped you little [ __ ] Oh God
it's fine everything's fine you still
down there do I even want to check okay
all right then just gonna skedaddle
because something's behind me everything
is goddamn killing me in this place okay
I need to get back just a little bit
farther now I need to make my way to the
light containment area which I know
there's probably a juncture what is this
what was this again
oh this was the area where he came from
that's why I dropped all my [ __ ] okay
all right then and I definitely can't go
through here because it's it's been
locked down yeah it's been locked down
so there's no point in all of that so
there is a way to go over fear and I'm
gonna take off my gas mask because I
can't see anything okay all right so I
think if we go south here this should
take us to where we need to go and then
I believe if I [ __ ] forgot about this
where does this lead hang on let me
double-check over here where does this
lead okay what is this again doesn't
want to be thorough about this and I
don't want to be blocking off my paths
anywhere oh yeah oh yeah oh I forgot
about you and I forgot about the thing I
needed the suit for oh yeah oh
[Music]
where'd he go where did he go okay
alrighty then
okay I guess I'm going to open the door
[Music]
okay oh okay am I stuck here now I
vaguely remember something about this
working and it did I don't think it went
like this
I can't do anything hello hello hi okay
alrighty then damn it damn it I think I
got bugged in here I gotta I think I
gotta load my save and come back ok I'm
back I just crossed the chasm that's
from where I just came so this should be
to do that at least we know that radical
Aries now gonna be able to bother us
anymore hard donkey are you doing you
still being a son of a [ __ ] yeah but
you're you second [ __ ] alright so if I
go I believe it's down here but I don't
know if this is going to be open to me
yes it is cuz this is where Larry first
popped in and not first popped in but
this is where he'd bother does anyway
nothing's gonna bother us though now
[ __ ] hell Jesus there's none oh yeah
the Larry goop I forgot about that
oh and I forgot about this elevator
where does this one go and do I want to
go in it got on a save you first was
there a place to save around here oh I
know Billy's gonna be around every
corner but just hoping one can hope and
dream hello ah good a defunct
containment area Oh in here maybe hi how
the [ __ ] did you get there
ah I need to go through there thank you
very much
yes you know let me go mr. poop but
Billy boo cuz I need to go in here
excuse me please do not bother me I can
save here so that's where the Khmer
Script skull is which is what I
definitely do not need hi okay hello
buddy is that far enough oh I think
that's my blood why do you have a bloody
ear you know I don't want to know who
you've been killing alright okay it's
fine so was over here nothing okay so
I'm gonna use this to get away from him
just a bit just because I don't want to
be bothered
doodlee do okay so I'm gonna go down
here just because I got a little
sidetracked n8
ah good this elevator appears to be
broken Gonzales gym man [ __ ] you Jim
you're no good to anybody especially me
oh oh those are some reassuring snip
steps okay and there's another elevator
here nope
yeah they all appear to be broken maybe
I should use the blood as an indicator
then maybe these elevators aren't for me
Oh up here that's right up here was this
the area is it who the [ __ ] was that and
what's in here tor appears to be lucky
what are you doing oh hi okay I've no I
I don't even know okay so this isn't the
place where the this isn't where the
door control is but it looks a lot like
it it's definitely not it she's um she's
arms she's um zim zam zam alright it's
fine this is fine this is now where I'm
supposed to be I thought it was but it's
not so I just gotta keep going until I
find what I need
there's got to be a place to turn off
remote door control access I know that
exists because it existed in the last
one
Oh hi is there something in there that
I'm I need but I don't think I can get
in there okay and I know there's no way
no way at all this is a security
checkpoint it's fine
he didn't do his job very well he led
everyone through but it's fine oh okay
that's locked and I don't need to be
there so what I need to do is I need to
keep moving
oh ah is this still activated is that
gonna zip he zapped me into next century
probably let me go save before I go
charging through there cuz I can't
remember if something actually died on
that one or if it was just a fluke no
how did you get up there okay alright
you stay up there you stay I don't know
how you found me I'm gonna test this
thing out yeah I'm fine
surprisingly I am fine Oh another set of
these maybe what about this okay where
is that oh well I don't know what these
are wait and let me take these off oh
well alright then
ah is that the ring oh I need that I
need that because the ring scp-713 be
stored blah blah blah seemingly nothing
more than a Jade ring it is several
effects within moments of putting it on
where it feels worn out but this is
important because it has a mental shield
it's very very good for you to resist
like the quote unquote mimetic effect so
the meme effects and then it's supposed
to nullify the effect of various
chemicals in the body fully poisonous or
toxic substances are generally not
hindered and so what it means is I think
this ring is gonna allow me to survive
an encounter with the plague doctor I'm
not 100% sure about that but I think
that's what it's supposed to do because
if I put it on it doesn't do much for me
now but it does reduce my my ability to
run like greatly but if I take it off
I'll eventually recover I remember what
that is I'm hesitant to just pick things
up you know what I mean I'm gonna lock
that one in just in a second because the
things that I don't know what they are
they could very well kill me very easy
hello ah okay I'm going to drop a cup
I'm gonna pick up this key I forget what
this does it's either a key that unlocks
anything or it's a key that unlocks a
very specific door that takes me to like
ah the dimension I don't want to go to
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure that's
the encyclopedia of common diseases and
I'm not supposed to open that I'm pretty
sure that's what that is okay I need to
find I need to find a computer terminal
to save because I just got some goodies
and I don't want to lose them I know
there's a Billy over here who wants to
mess up my
and a fine one your RB okay so I just
saved and if I recall either this is the
book where you write a story in there
and it becomes true or it's the book
where when you read the diseases it
kills you I can't remember which so
let's find out I don't think I need this
flu all right ah common cold
also known as nazo it's a virus no cure
yep it's the one where you get every
disease that you read can I read this
again cancer a hook cancer of the lungs
well that's not good what's up next big
boy appendicitis
oh no well I don't have an appendix well
that's gonna kill me eventually
Kirti oh no oh oh well there I go I'm
dead so that's the bad one that is the
no good one I don't know why they just
keep that on a pedestal with no
information about it oh boy oh memory
access violation okay where that didn't
work out too well but that is all the
time I got for this episode so I'm gonna
find the remote door control and I'm
going to figure out a way beyond that
because I know I know for a fact there's
a remote door control around here
somewhere and I know for a fact that I
haven't explored absolutely everywhere I
still got o49 crawling up my butt but
now I got this blue key and I wonder
where it goes to I'm not entirely sure I
can't remember if that's the key that
sent me into a portal dimension or not
things get a little hazy after a few
years but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know how i'm
doing the comments
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]